فرنسا تنشر اربعين الف جندي مع تواصل
الاحتجاجات قائد فاجنر يكشف دوافع تحركه
باتجاه موسكو عوده الاشتباكات بالخرطوم
وهدوء في شمال دارفور
هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من قناه
العربيه فاهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
نبدا من التوتر في فرنسا والتي اتسعت فيها
رقعه الغضب واعمال الشغب احتجاجا على
مختلفه برصاص الشرطه الامر الذي دفع وزير
الداخليه للتوجيه بنشر اربعين الف رجل في
انحاء البلاد تحسبا لمزيد من العنف الوزير
سدد على ان رد الدوله سيكون حاسما لمواجهه
ما وصفها باعمال الشغب والتخريب من قبل
المحتجين في وقت قال فيه ممثل الادعاء
الفرنسي ان التحقيق جار مع الشرطي الذي
قتل الفتى والذي ينحدر من شمال افريقيا
مضيفا انه يواجه تهمه القتل العمد
في تسجيل صوتي جديد كشف قائد ومؤسس مجموعه
فاغنر الروسيه
التمرد المؤقت الذي نفذته مجموعته قبل
ايام ضد قال ان قوته توقفت عن التمرد في
اللحظه التي اصبح فيها من الواضح ان
الكثير من الدماء سيرراق مشددا انه على
انه كان على بعد نحو 200 كيلومتر فقط من
العاصمه الروسيه موسكو واضاف اكتفت بعرض
قوتها ولم يكن لديها هدف للاطاحه بالحكومه
الحاليه او الرئيس مؤكدا انه اراد تحقيق
العداله فقط
مكدت الاشتباكات في السودان تنتهي حتى
عادت مجددا فبعد انتهاء هدنه العيد التي
كانت ليوم واحد فقط حلقت طائرات حربيه
وسمع اطلاق نار متقطع من اسلحه ثقيله في
العاصمه الخرطوم وجنوب ام درمان حيث اكد
مراسل العربيه ان الطيران الحربي شن ضربات
جويه على اهداف متفرقه في الخرطوم فيما
اعلن والي شمال دارفور نمر محمد عبد
الرحمن الاتفاق على وقت القتال في الولايه
بين الاطراف المتصارعه هناك من اجل السلام
والاستقرار على حد وصفه
والى عالم الفضاء حيث تخطط وكاله الفضاء
الامريكيه ناسا للبدء في عمليات استخراج
تجريبيه لموارد القمر قبل عام 2032 وستكون
اولى العمليات مخصصه لاستخراج الماء
والاكسجين من تربه القمر ثم استخراج
الحديد والمعادن من الارضيه النادره ووفقا
لجرل ساندرز عالم الصواريخ في ناسا فستجرى
اولى تجارب استخراج الخامات خلال العقد
المقبل وتنوي ناس تقييم حجم الموارد بما
فيها الطاقه والماء وتربه القمر من اجل
جذب الاستثمارات حيث تخطط لارسال جهاز حفر
تجريبي الى القمر قريبا وبناء مصنع
لمعالجه الخامات على سطحه
نختم من امريكا حيث نقلت نجمه موسيقى
البوب الشهيره مادونا الى وحده العنايه
المركزه في احدى المستشفيات بعد تاكيد
اصابتها بعدوا بكتيريه خطيره وفقا للاطباء
المشرفين على حالتها
وكانت لها جوله حول العالم من المقرر ان
تبدا في الخامس عشر من يوليو المقبل في
فانكوفر وتنتهي في ديسمبر بامستردام قال
مدير اعمالها انه ان صحتها تتحسن لكنها لا
تزال تحت الرعايه الطبيه المركزه